[Music]
about every six days ghostly images of
most areas on earth emerge from the
european space
agency's sentinel-1 program the
technology capturing these images
synthetic aperture radar also known as
sar
is booming in the coming years it may
reveal
tiny changes on every patch of earth
daily optical imagery satellites
like the u.s geological survey's landsat
use reflected light to passively take
photos from high in the sky sentinel one
takes its snapshots actively
by using radars unlike optical
technology
which produces the best images on sunny
days
sar penetrates clouds and works at night
an antenna on board the satellite emits
microwave
pulses to the surface of the earth and
records the echoes that bounce back
the more signals it gathers the higher
the resolution of the image
the synthetic aperture of sar satellites
describes an
important advance instead of building an
extremely
large antenna to capture returning waves
these satellites combine signals from a
relatively small
antenna moving through space to sharpen
resolution
by comparing measurements from different
positions sar data can reveal topography
images are often colorized to highlight
important features
such as flooded regions
what started as a tool for military
surveillance is now essential to earth
scientists examining changes in
landscape over time
comparing sar images from the same
vantage point at different times can
reveal
surface movements from meters to
millimeters
this technique is known as
interferometric sar
or insar one of the first applications
emerged in 1989
when researchers observed the subtle
swelling of fields in california's
imperial valley
after crops were irrigated in 1993
a groundbreaking study used insar to
reveal how the ground
shifted after a powerful earthquake
rippled through landers california
colors on the map show meters of
movement concentrated along the faults
the technique also revealed changes in
the land
miles away from the earthquake's
epicenter
two years later glaciologists used insar
to measure the flow of ice streams in
greenland
which accelerated as the planet warmed
more recently geophysicists were able to
detect
signs of deformation at several
volcanoes in the east african rift zone
some of which were thought to be
inactive the corbetti volcano near the
city of owasa ethiopia
has been inflating by almost seven
centimeters a year
the launch of twin sentinel-1 satellites
in 2014
and 2016 provided researchers with
regular freely available data
norway used sentinel 1 data to create a
deformation map of the entire country
in order to identify rockslide hazards
inadvertently they discovered that parts
of the train station in oslo were
sinking
private companies are also investing in
sar technology
isai a finnish space startup plans to
launch
eight or more satellites in 2021 adding
to its growing fleet
already in orbit ultimately they hope to
capture snapshots of
most places on earth several times per
day
and produce images with 50 centimeter or
higher resolution
researchers envision close to real-time
sar observations
to change the way we live it could
provide
crucial information on natural disasters
such as floods
quickly identifying the most inundated
areas can guide response efforts
the applications are just beginning to
be conceived